electric cars aren't
you don't get the same range they're not
as practical they come with
inconveniences recycling of the
batteries is problematic they're quite
heavy too I mean one of the things that
I've noticed personally especially in
the winter time here is
I was driving down this back road and it
was me there was a Tesla in front of me
and then there was a big ass salt plow
truck and the big asphalt plow truck
used plowing you know the snow off the
road throwing down some salt
and he had to come to a stop I don't
know what to do what maybe there was
something on the road in front of them
but he came to a stop at a reasonable
speed the Tesla because they're so damn
heavy but the battery packs
hits the brakes and he's and he couldn't
stop in time to avoid hitting the back
of the snowplow right so things in
motion like to keep doing what they're
already doing right basic you know
physics
um I don't know what my car weighs let's
say it's probably about 3 000 pounds
standard standard power you know gas
powered car the equivalent size electric
car usually weighs about 1100 1200
pounds more so you hit brakes on a car
and you're still going but you're on a
slippery surface and you're not getting
grip the stopping distance is quite a
bit longer so dude slides into the back
of the snowplow I didn't have a problem
stopping at all I was basically at the
same distance behind him as he was
behind the snow plow he had the snow
plow I was totally fine I'm just like
okay you guys have fun with that now you
need
cops and tow truck and all this stuff
but yeah like there's like there's some
inherent issues in them that you don't
have with petroleum power cars the
internal combustion is a wonderful thing
it's very efficient
um like
somebody what's what's his name um
there's this kid he's not a kid anymore
but he was a kid when he started his
channel it's called engineering
explained and he did a comparison
between electric cars and petroleum cars
and one of the
um stages of the comparisons that he was
talking about was he basically had like
a
liter of water and he said let's pretend
this is gasoline the amount of energy
that's stored in a liter of water is the
equivalent to basically this entire
table over here and also liter bottles
in size so you need quite a bit of
storage capacity for the amount of
energy that's stored in a liter of
gasoline gasoline has a lot of energy
stored in it it's it's remarkable and
the engine itself is the formidable
piece of engineering I mean the fact
that they've been around for so long and
they become you know this efficient is
is is quite interesting I'm not opposed
to electric cars I'm not opposed to the
electrification of cars in fact I like
the idea of hybrid performance Vehicles
if you've ever driven a hybrid sports
car or an exotic car they are insane
like they they have the immediacy of uh
torque right from you know the moment
you slam the gas like they launch hard
and then the gas engine can just rip the
car through the higher RPMs so it's kind
of The Best of Both Worlds they're a
little bit heavier so there's somewhat
of an inconvenience but they generally
don't run all on battery power so they
have small electric motor and generally
speaking like a seven kilowatt eight
kilowatt hour battery
something that they can Market while oh
you could just drive on the battery
alone for you know 20 22 miles or
something like that some you know some
[__] like that which is fine so the
electrification of cars and performance
ends I'm all for that I like it I've
driven them they're great
um I'm looking forward to whatever
replaces the McLaren 720 it's probably
going to have some sort of hybrid motor
system that's like in the Arturo which
is more like the entry level so I think
it's a good thing but where they're
going with it like the way they're going
about it is they don't even want you to
have cars they want you to have if
you're going to have a car then what you
have an electric car and then beyond
that then they want to start taking them
away or they want to put systems in
place that are going to prevent you from
fully enjoying them so let's go over
here
um
where's the next one that I want to show
you so we did the liberal plan they want
to crank up the price of gas to make it
even more expensive that's what
everybody wants they want to pay more
for their [__] because we're not really
paying enough right now with inflation
so this is the last slide and then we'll
start taking some uh call-ins in a
moment but there is some legislation
right now
going on
where they want to install kill switches
in all new cars now some people have
been saying that
and I've seen this on Twitter in a few
videos that that this is why they want
you to drive electric cars because they
can put kill switches in them [__]
they can put a kill switch in any car
with a computer in it they can put a
kill switch in brand new gas powered
cars that are coming off the production
line right now and they can control it
with the sell signal and prevent you
from driving that car at any time even
if it's a gas car so it's not like they
want you in electric cars to put kill
switches in it they want to put kill
switches in everything now the angle
that they're going to use is well for
safety reasons I think there's a a
photograph in it here we go well for
safety reasons in case we have like a
high speed Pursuit we can just turn off
that car of the push push of a button
not in danger of the public nobody will
die everything is safe it's easy for us
to catch the perp blah blah blah that's
that's the story that that they're going
to use
but that's truthfully I think we both
know that's not how they're going to use
it the technology exists today like I
know that in the United Kingdom
police cars have
um scanners they're basically cameras
right and I don't know if they have them
in the rear but but I know for sure they
have them in the front but let's assume
they have them in the front and rear so
the cops driving around he's drinking
his coffee he's got a donut everything's
good tap on the computer and then all of
a sudden he gets alert bong bong bong
and it says that car over there has
expired insurance or that car over there
um he's wanted for something because the
camera scans
scans the license plate number it goes
up in the database the database Compares
it to whether or not their insurance is
up to date if there's anything
outstanding and then it notifies the cop
and the cops like okay I'm going to pull
that guy over well they're already
scanning you they already like the
technology is already in place where
they can detect you but now they want to
add new technology in your own personal
vehicle that you pay money for you you
go and make your money you pay your
taxes on your money and then you go and
buy your car which is a source of
Freedom or always has been a source of
Freedom ever since I've been around and
you know granted yes I'm dated okay
you're a little bit older rich yeah but
this is the way things are going guys
so picture this they could actually set
it up so it's like oh and then the car
shuts down and it forces him to pull
over because they all have autopilot now
you know for the most part so imagine
the text expired pull them over fine
seems reasonable right seems Seems like
it's a reasonable you don't want an O.J
Simpson type of scenario
some people are going who's O.J Simpson
well kids let me tell you
yeah okay so back in the day O.J Simpson
right he uh he was running from the cops
on the California highways and they shut
down the entire Highway and there was
video footage here let me see if I can
find a picture because this because this
is like embedded in the minds of like
everybody from my era right O.J Simpson
white Bronco
Highway
case let's see how many cops were in
that photograph I can't I can't remember
now but I know it was a lot
uh images
yeah here we go so at the Stream
so this is O.J Simpson in his white Ford
Bronco this is the original one I think
it was like an 89 or something like that
with all of California State Highway
Patrol behind them so the argument is
well we can just push a button to shut
it off and we'll get OJ and not not
endanger anybody you know similar sort
of thing but I don't think that's how
they're going to use it so let's so
let's read the article here
throw back up on the screen
um so according to article written by
former U.S representative Bob Barr
hidden away in the recently passed
infrastructure Bill the one that sorry
the very one that I wore before
negatively impacts drivers across the
country if it were to pass which it will
because it's an infrastructure bill is a
measure to install vehicle kill switch
in every new car truck and suv sold in
this country the regulation won't be
enforced for five years so maybe there's
time to do something about this yeah
but we've seen this in other countries
and they're all leading towards the same
sort of thing where they want to
basically have all law abiding citizens
have this device in their vehicle they
may mention over here something that
happened in New Zealand so this is where
they might actually use it this is an
example they're saying for example in
September a car was pulled over in New
Zealand way over on the other side of
the world
and the occupants were arrested when
police discovered the trunk was full of
ARS guns drugs cocaine no
Kentucky Fried Chicken meals
okay they were smuggling the fast food
to customers in lockdown Auckland New
Zealand against quarantine measures so
this is what they want to use lock you
know shutting down your car for
smuggling Kentucky Fried Chicken in the
next scandemic
anyway so there's a photograph of that
event
um it's even better
uh the bill which has been signed to law
by President Biden states that the kill
switch which is to be referred as a
safety device because of course they
would call it a kill switch they want to
call it a safety device must passively
monitor the performance of the driver of
a motor vehicle to accurately identify
whether the driver may be impaired now
I don't know how they're going to
determine whether or not you're drunk
driving again this is this is how they
push bills in Parliament it's for your
safety we don't want you smuggling
Kentucky Fried Chicken across the border
in the next scandemic we gotta you know
we got to put the uh put the brakes down
on that
and then the other thing that they
mentioned in the bill as well is we'll
be able to monitor if you're drunk or
stone driving your car now I don't know
how they're going to monitor if you're
impaired driving a vehicle
they might I don't know like like let's
let's sort of think this through maybe
if you're swerving through Lane sort of
thing and you don't normally drive that
way in the car but here's the problem
that I have with it if it's not just a
kill switch meaning somebody can push a
button to shut off your car but it's
also monitoring how you use your car all
the time
well I know right now my daily driver
it's an Audi it's a 2018 model
and it currently as I'm driving will
read uh traffic signs and tell me what
the speed limit is it puts a little box
in the kind of in the bottom of the
console and it says you know your speed
limit here is 60 kilometers an hour so
the camera knows what the speed limit is
the car knows what my speed is so what's
stopping them from cross-referencing
those two and that I get a like a bill
in the mail for going 12 kilometers an
hour over the speed limit right this is
potentially going to be a problem beyond
what they're telling you it's not going
to be a problem for again they're saying
it's a safety device
anyway in other words big brother will
constantly be monitoring how you drive
if you do something the system has been
programmed to recognize as driver
impairment your car could be shut off
which could also be incredibly dangerous
I mean you'd want to have it shut off
but on the shoulder of the road not in
the middle of the road I'm sure they
would build that into that it seems kind
of absurd they wouldn't
there's a possibility the kill switch
program might measure your driving as
impaired when you try to start a car
again the car won't fire up that could
potentially leave you stranded even if
you're not impaired so you know there's
it's just you know there's issues to
this so they keep going on but wait
there's more the kill switch safety
system would be open or in other words
there would be a back door that would
allow police or other government
authorities to access it whenever they
want
which they kind of do right now anyway
they're monitoring all the time
would they need a warrant to do to that
probably not even better hackers could
access the back door and shut down your
vehicle
anyway this guy points out violations of
privacy human rights all kinds of issues
um you know you guys can go check out
the article here the title of it is law
will instill kill switches into all new
cars
so I don't know there's look they're
cooking up some plans they're cooking up
some plans they don't want you having
cars they don't want you have an
autonomy they don't want you having
freedom
I think this is going to be used Beyond
just the intended purposes they're
talking about right now to pass
legislation I think they're going to use
this
um for the next scam endemic like if
they don't want you leaving the house
for example
okay let's push buttons here here here
here and here and you people in these
jurisdictions are not allowed to drive
your car and you get up in the morning
to go get in your car because you want
to get a coffee at the drive through
like you did during the last scandemic
with your stupid face diaper on and you
know hand sanitizer everywhere and you
can't even drive your car anymore or
beyond that what about climate lockdowns
because you know that the world economic
Forum doesn't want you driving your car
because they're saying that they pollute
too much even though they're flying in
with their private jets 22 miles
you can run 22 miles people run those in
marathons
but they don't want you using your cars
and if they have these devices installed
in more of the cars and it stops you
from using them so it's a control
mechanism
this this is where you are this is where
we are okay I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out